in 2008 my next guest became an internet
sensation and mad tv cast member thanks
to her viral nail salon routine
since then she's appeared on shows like
super store ugly betty as well as curb
your enthusiasm and released
four one hour specials already on august
20th you can see her hosting
the art of comedy special which was shot
at the ha festival in san antonio
please welcome angela johnson angela
thank you for being here
thank you for having me that was a
mouthful sorry to give you every credit
possible all of it you text me word by
word
once um how are how are you and your
husband handling
the the quarantine the whole lockdown
you know we're actually having a great
time
which sometimes i i try not to tell
everybody how much fun we're having
because i know there's a lot of hurt
happening in the world so
i like to be like i hate it but really
love it so much
um i'm a homebody love to be home and
we're getting creative like we all have
celebrated birthdays in quarantine
so far um my husband's birthday is july
so we did christmas in july
because he loves christmas we decorated
we put the christmas tree out
all the decorations everywhere and we
did christmas in july for like a good
three weeks almost the whole month i
feel like you could almost get away with
it in the long term we're at a point
where every day
feels the same i couldn't tell you what
the date is today
i feel like if i just saw christmas
decorations well i guess it's christmas
now they're probably right
they're probably right dang it yeah i
miss that too
that's why that's why they're drinking
in the middle of the afternoon
uh cheers i'm drinking the ginger max
what do you got over there
cheers look at this
yes um i watched it last night
the the art of comedy which is a cool
way to set up comedy oh thanks for
watching it
yeah and and you're the host of it and i
don't know you maybe you could tell me
maybe wrong but it look like you're
having a lot of fun
what was your favorite part about
shooting the special um my favorite part
about
shooting this special with other comics
is that there was other comics there
because i'm used to being on the road by
myself it's
me my opener my road manager and
that's it and then we're on the road and
then when we come home
most comics will like go hit up the
comedy store the improv
factory whatever a lot of times i just
want to be home because like i said i'm
a homebody i like that part
so i'll do like dinner with my friends
or just stay home and watch lawn art svu
in my own
bed or my own pouch and then pack and
get back on the road again
so a lot of times i'm just with three
people my road manager and my opener and
that's it
so my one of my favorite parts was
the camaraderie with the other comics
and being backstage and then
hanging out after having drinks after
and like that whole thing that was
probably
my favorite part was hanging out with
everybody i know what you mean because
when you get to your
success level you always get a little
isolated from what
when you start when you're in the clubs
with everyone every night or you're
just grinding out trying to get sets
anywhere when you get to your level it's
like well
now you're just on the road and yeah
you've got all those people but then the
show's over you have really no one to
decompress with and talk comics talk
away that is i know you can't be that
mean to any other people
who can be mean to comics they have a
special way it's a nice language
yeah we have a special way this special
was uh a debut
for one of my friends pedro celina so i
started out doing open mics with
no way how cool yeah just like the worst
rooms that we performed in a room that
was a juice bar
and the blender would start immediately
which is very exciting it was cool to
see him get his first
tv set for your first set because it's a
different experience
than just doing a club my first tv set
was
premium blend on comedy central years
ago
and um it was a bunch of comics and then
they would have like a headliner hosting
it
um jeff dunham was my host the puppet
god yeah
yes and then um on my episode was also
a comic she ended up falling off you may
not have heard of her amy schumer
does she run a crawfish room in deep san
diego
she used to yeah she used to do that i
think
i think she worked at massage envy now
yeah
that's huge that's a huge first taping
yeah and i like i was i was joking
saying like our careers went at
different paces
but you know what it's fine we're we're
all doing our own journey here
okay well one thing that stood out to me
that i really appreciated
is you you're hosting this thing not
only did you get everyone's name right
it's crucial
but you gave really nice intros to
everyone we almost feel like you know
the comic before they get up so you
don't have to do that extra step of
digging yourself out be like here's who
i am
that's right i really appreciated the
intros you gave so
thank you for doing that and also i'm
sure you've gotten bad intros
in your career i mean the worst
intros i've witnessed people get some
real bad ones
where it's like super cringe-worthy yeah
um one time i was at the improv
and um you know it's one of those nights
where just whoever
goes up and somebody's hosting it and
the guy that was going up next i forget
who it was but he was pretty famous like
more famous for acting than stand-up i
remember but it's like you've seen him
in like so many different movies type of
guy
and whoever was hosting forgot his name
so he does that whole thing where he
goes this next comic
he needs no introduction i mean you've
seen him everywhere
he doesn't even need an intro just come
on out here
and then it's like all of us are like oh
he totally forgot his name clearly
vamping this person
what a human being what a guy that's
that's not just a guy he's also
you know a girl in a way everyone is
everyone and what is the universe even
like oh you're just it's not going to
come to you also that type of intro like
you donated intro like it better be
the biggest person in the world sure if
you don't say
he doesn't need an intro please welcome
dave chappelle then it's like
oh you forgot his bio then right
right the worst for me is corporate gigs
okay
why this is why because here you are
sitting in this like conference room of
whatcha
tech company blah blah blah right and so
they're not used to
introducing entertainers that's not what
they do they just have like
you know susan from hr who's gonna read
your bio
you know and we're like at the club we
we know like the last thing you hear
is the comic's name and then they come
up right and usually at a corporate gig
it's something like
and this performer we're happy to bring
up
angela johnson and then i start walking
out and they go
she has been and then they've named
everything i've ever done from the
sniffers commercial when i was 23
to like what i did yesterday and then
after like
a good 10 minute intro then they're like
come on out
so you're at this point already on the
stage you're like well
i heard my name and that's when we know
to go up and then you have to hear
whatever wikipedia thing they downloaded
sure sure sure i remember i got brought
up once we're like and from the
contra it was like my name first and i'm
already on stage just like hunched over
in the dark
and then i was like from the
controversial burger king commercial
here he is like okay well i didn't like
do anything with the burgers there's
like a different reason
i was like there's a controversial
burger king commercial wait a minute i
guess it set off everyone's like home
assistant
alexa or zuri or something and it made
sense oh i didn't know that
yeah well it was like on purpose and
then um
for some reason that made it into the
stage intro and that was
it's a college campus was like wait
controversy what did he do
yeah yeah who do you sleep with there
you go he slept with one of the burgers
which i wouldn't put it past men
yeah yeah in this special the art of
comedy
uh some of the comics perform on a
riverboat which just kind of pitches us
like hell gig because it's like outdoors
tourists but i don't know the longer i
don't perform on stage
i was weird watching it because i'm like
i think i'd do that gig now
that was the cool call out in this
special but he doesn't know
uh evan gloria is makes an appearance
yeah and special to uh to introduce it
was cool to be a part of something
with her like this and honestly to
acknowledge like our culture
you know what i mean like to acknowledge
that there
are funny latino people
funny like we're really talented and
let's highlight some of us like that
that was an honor to do
because a lot of time i mean like we're
we're making fun like diversity matters
though and so
yeah that's why i was really super
honored to be a part of
this special and hosting it because
i want to see our stories told and you
know
like we deserve that they're great
stories
yeah there's a really cool way that hbo
max framed it and that it's the art of
comedy and it's not
billed as these shows we get to feature
these people that are just have
interesting points of views
and kind of the fact that they're latin
or spanish has really nothing to do with
just that they're good at stand up
because a lot of times when you first
start your career it's like well we need
a separate night for all the latin
people
it's i see saturdays oh i did refried
fridays for many years
nothing feels better than getting a
check that says refried fridays on it
just from my name alone uh it doesn't
seem like just a bland white guy name
i would get put on chocolate sundaes
really
urban show yeah oh yeah yeah okay
two of them name alone i think i did it
like once or twice chocolate some days
angela this was so much fun talking to
you thank you so much for doing the show
you're so funny and it's really special
that i got to be on this
with you so thank you for having me art
of comedy is the special
and cheers
you